السلام عليكم ورحمه الله صحيح ان الاحكام
الجديده الصادره فيما تعرف بقضيه غرفه
عمليه رابع ما تزال قاسيه في حق بعض من
شملتهم الى انها تبقى لافته مقارنه
بمحاكمه اولى في قض في القضيه ذاتها توسعت
في توزيع احكام الاعدام والمؤبد
احكام يوم الاثنين تضمنت تبرئه عدد كبير
من المتهمين ولا حديث فيها عن حالات اعدام
وهو امر يختلف كليا عن اخرى صدرت في نيسان
ابريل
2015 في جميع الا حوال يفرد السياق
السياسي نفسه بل يتجاوز التفاصيل
القانونيه عند الحديث عما يصدر من القضاء
المصري في السنوات الاخيره يحاول وضع
الاحكام في سياقها والبدايه بتقرير ولد
العطار بشكل نهائي يسدل الستار على القضيه
التي عرفت اعلاميا بغرفه عمليات رابعه
ثلاثه احكام بالمؤبد كانت من نصيب محمد
بديع مرشد جماعه الاخوان واثنين من اعضاء
مكتب الارشاد وفضلا عن الحكم بالسجن
المشدد خمس سنوات على 14 متهما اخرين قضت
المحكمه التي عرضت امامها القضيه للمره
الثانيه ببراءه 21 متهما تكتسب القضيه
بعدا اعلاميا لاسباب منها عدد الصحفيين
المتهمين بهاها سواء منهم من حكم بخمس
سنوات اخيرا او من نال البراءه فالجميع
قضوا قرابه ثلاث سنوات او تزيد في سجون
كالعقرب وغيره مما تواترت التقارير
الحقوقيه بسوء سمعتها وبشاعه ما يتعرض له
نزلائها من انتهاكات غير ادميه عرضت حياه
كثيرين منهم للخطر ولا يعني تخفيف الاحكام
او الغائها في قضيه كهذه كثيرا لبعض
المتهمين ممن ادرجت اسمائهم في عشرات
القضايا منذ الانقلاب كما لم يذكر القاضي
كيف يمكن تعويض من حكم ببراءتهم عن تلك
الايام والليالي التي شرفوا فيها على
الهلاك محرومين من اسرهم
وابنائهم ذاكره هذه القضيه مشاهد كهذه
ادخل فيها الناشط الشاب محمد سلطان الى
المحكمه محمولا بعد اضرابه عن الطعام خلال
الحبس بينما وقف والده صلاح سلطان عضو
الاتحاد العالمي لعلماء المسلمين مطالبا
بانقاذه الاب وولده حكما بخمس سنوات غير
ان حكم الابن جاء غيابيا للافراج عنه صحيا
زوايا عديده بالمشهد تستحق التوقف منها
تلك الفجوه الضخمه بين هذه الاحكام وبين
الاحكام الصاد في المره السابقه بذات
القضيه انذاك حكم على 14 متهما بالاعدام
وعلى 66 بالسجن المؤبد الغاء الاعدامات
بالكامل وتخفيض المؤبدات على هذا النحو قد
يضعه البعض في صالح النظام القضائي المصري
لكن اخرين يرون فيه تساهلا في اصدار احكام
اعدام بالجمله اثار استنكارات حقوقيه
واسعه ومس سمعه القضاء في مصر بعد انقلاب
يوليو لكن هل ما زال النظام المصري حقا
بحاجه لاحكام الاعدام في صراعه مع معارضيه
سؤال قد يجيب عنه ارتفاع وتيره التصفيه
الجسديه والقتل الميداني خارج اطار
القانون وهي توصيفات حقوقيه لما تمارسه
السلطات المصريه بشكل شبه يومي مما تقول
انه تصفيه لمطلوبين خلال مواجهه مزعومه
بين هذا المسار وبين قضيه رابعه نفسها نسب
وصله فالمتهم سواء في قضيه غرفه رابعه او
قضيه فض الاعتصام كلهم او جلهم كان معتصما
داخل الميدان في ذلك النهار الدامي من
اغسطس اب
2013 وكانوا جميعا عرضه لرصاص الجيش
والشرطه المصريين الذي ارضى المئات خلال
تلك المجزره غير المسبوقه في التاريخ
المصري الحديث كما يقول حقوقيون يعلق
محامو المتهمين في هذه القضايا على ذلك
بان موكليهم لا يحاكمون ربما الا على
النجاه من الموت يوم المذبحه
لنقاش نوسع في هذا الموضوع انضموا الينا
من القاهره عبر سكايب اسعد هيكل المحامي
والباحث السياسي ومن لندن وائل قنديل
الكاتب الصحفي المصري مرحبا بضيفي
الكريمين استاذ اسعد هيكل كيف تنظر الى
هذه الاحكام الصادره اليوم من محكمه
جنايات الجيزه في قضيه غرفه عمليات رابعه
وفي في اي سياق
تضعها يعني اضع هذه الاحكام في سياقها
القضائي
المعتاد محكمه النقد كانت قد
الغت يعني عدد كبير من احكام الاعدام وصل
في هذه القضيه الى 14 حكم باعدام عدد من
قيادات الاخوان المسلمين على راسهم مرشد
الجماعه نفسه محمد بديع وبالتالي رات
محكمه الجنايات اليوم ان هذه الاحكام او
ان هذه الوقائع التي يحاكم المتهمون
بشانها لا تستحق تجديد العقوبه الى هذا
الحد
وخففت هذه الاحكام الى السجن المؤبد فقط
بالنسبه لمرشد الجماعه وخففت ايضا الاحكام
الى اخرين حتى انها انتهت الى براءه 21
عضو من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين دعني يعني
لا اكون ملكيا اكثر من الملك
واهنئ جماعه الاخوان المسلمين على تخفيف
هذه الاحكام واشير في هذا الصدد الى بعض
من التصريحات التي صدرت من رموز او اعضاء
بعض هذه الجماعه التي رحبت بتخفيف هذه
الاحكام
وبالتالي لا استطيع ان ازايد واقول ان
هناك يعني مبالغه او تشدد في عقاب اعضاء
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بل اقول اليوم
القضاء المصري خفف من حده هذه الاحكام
انعكاسا في حقيقه الامر يعني نعم طيب الى
الى تخفيف حده المواجهه ايضا بين جماعه
الاخوان والسلطه السياسيه في مصر استاذ
وائل القنديل تخفيف هذه الاحكام في هذه
القضيه الا يعد مؤشرا ايجابيا من جانب
النظام على الاطلاق لا يعد اي مؤشر ايجابي
من جانب النظام لانه في اللحظه التي بيتم
فيها تخفيف بعض الاحكام على على المتهمين
في قضيه عبثيه غيبيه كما وصفها الدفاع في
البدايه لدكتور محمد سليم العوه عندما قال
ان مذكره تحريات ضابط الشرطه بتتحدث عن
اشياء مستقبليه غيبيه اذا لم تكن هناك
قضيه من الاساس في نفس هذه اللحظه النظام
بيصفي ثم
من الشباب بدون اي محاكمات فقط اعتقلهم
واعلن واعلن عن اعتقالهم بالامس واليوم
بيعلن عن تصفيتهم في اثناء اشتباكات يعني
هم الان يريدون ان يقولوا الرساله الصادره
من النظام الان انه لا داعي للمحاكمات
وكانها استجابه للدعوه التي انطلقت من
اعلاميين وسياسيين منذ فتره طويله بتقول
ان هؤلاء الذين يحاكمون والذين هم في
المعتقلات يكلفون ميزانيه دوله غذاء وعاش
في السجون ف لا ينبغي ان ننفق على
محاكمتهم فلنت خص منهم بدون اي محاكمه
بدون اي مسائله نعدم دون اي عرض على قضاء
مستقل او قضاء عموما يعني الان بيتم
الترجمه الحرفيه لهذا انهم يعني باختصار
بالمعنى الدارج في مصر يعني فكوا تخفيف
الحكم الاعدام على المرشد الاخوان بتصفيه
ثمانيه شباب بالاضافه الى انه هناك حمله
اعتقالات مسعوره بتتم في
داخل القوى السياسيه عموما ليس الاسلاميين
وليس جماعه الاخوان المسلمين فقط منذ ايام
وكلما
بتقترب
ذكره 30 يونيو وما الى ذلك بتزيد هذه
الاعتقالات وشفنا احنا يعني زوار الفجر
عادوا مره اخرى للاعتقال في الاسكندريه
وفي اماكن كثيره واليوم النهارده يعني
عندما يكون هناك احد الشباب الذين اعلن عن
تصفيتهم اليوم اتصل بذويه امس في محافظه
المنوفيه وقال لوالده انه معتقل في في في
مدينه الغردقه او في تاريخ سفاجه وانه
سيعرض على النيابه صباح الغد ثم يعلم عن
تصفيته اثناء اشتباكات فانت امام نظام لم
يعد حتى يعني يبذل مجهودا في هندسه الكذب
او الاخراج كذبه لطيفه ت طكن استذ استاذ
استاذ وائل يعني انت قلت بانه لا لا لا
مؤشرات ايجابيه من جانب النظام من خلال
هذه الاحكام ولكن الا يمكن ان ننظر الى
تخفيف هذه الاحكام من زاويه اعتبارها
انفراجه سياسيه
او لنقول مبادره لتخفيف الاحتقان السياسي
والامني في
البلاد اين الانفراج السياسيه وهو في وائل
قدي بتكلمني استاذ عبد الصمد ولا بتكلم
وائل قنديل يا طيب اهلا بك يعني يعني كيف
تكون مبادره ايجابيه وهو في اللحظه التي
بيخفف فيها بعض هذه الاحكام
ويعني يعني انا انا اندهش طبعا انا كل
الذين حصلوا على براءه وكل الذين خففت
احكامهم كلهم يستحقون البراءه منذ لانه لا
توجد قضيه بالاساس يعني نحن يعني هذا خبر
جيد ان يحصل مواطن على حريته بعد اربع
سنوات من التعذيب والتنكيل والحبس بلا اي
جريمه فهذا جيب ولكن في اللحظه ذاتها التي
بيصدر فيها هذا الحكم بيتم تصفيه ثمانيه
شباب بنفس الطريقه يعني اذا كانت هذه
القضيه بنيت طيب عندما قدمت للقضاء
على تصورات او تهيؤات لدى ضابط التحريات
بيتحدث عن انهم كانوا
ينتون الدوله المصريه
بتصف اليوم وتقول انهم كانوا ينتهون السفر
يعني اذا كانت لا توجد قضيه في الاساس
وهنا السؤال لاسعد هيكل تحديدا وقضيه
عبثيه غيبيه كما وصف الدفاع في البدايه
يعني هذه القضيه اصلا
تخص ما يوصف بمجزره رابعه العدويه
فهؤلاء الذين يحاكمون هل يمكن ان نصفهم
بالجنات الحقيقيين ام اصلا هم
الضحايا لا انا اعتقد يعني انا لم اقرا
بعد اسباب او حيثيات الحكم التي الذي صدر
اليوم محكمه الجنايات لكن في الحد الادنى
من العقوبه تستطيع يعني باعتباري يعني
متخصص في الشان القانوني تستطيع ان ت رجع
تخفيف هذه الاحكام والاكتفاء فقط بالسجن
المؤبد ضد مرشد الاخوان الى تطبيق ماده
عقاب واضحه هي ن 86 العقو العقوبه على
قياده وتاسيس جماعه على خلاف القانون هي
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين هذه الجماعه حتى
الان وضعها القانوني غير يعني صحيح منذ
اسست عام 28 هذا هو الحد الادنى للعقاب
الذي استطيع ان يعني اتوقعه من صدور هذا
الحكم المخفف بعد استبعاد احكام الاعدام
التي قد تكون مرجعها الى ارتكاب هذه
الجماعه عمليات عنف عمليات قتل اثناء
اعتصام رابعه
العدويه في شكل تحريض يعني وائ
قضين جماعه غير قانونيه ولهذا هم
يعاقبون هذا غير صحيح في في الوقت الذي
قدمت فيه هذه القضيه وفي الوقت الذي
ارتكبت فيه مجزره ربعه العدويه كانت الج
جماعه قانونيه وكانت تتمتع بالوضعيه
القانونيه والوضعيه الادبيه داخل المجتمع
المصري بدليل
انه المشير طنطاوي والفريق سامي عنام في
حفل تنصيب الرئيس محمد مرسي كان يعني
يقفان بين يدي مرشد الاخوان كتلميذ يعني
ويج لان هو يتحدث بالاضافه الى ان هذه
الجماعه سمح لها بتاسيس حزب سياسي حاز
الاغلبيه في انتخابات 2012 ثم فاز مرشح
هذه الجماعه بمنصب رئيس الجمهوريه وادى
القسم وبالتالي الكلام عن عدم قانونيه هذه
الجماعه قبل مجز صحيح صدر بعد مجزره ربعه
العدويه بعد الانقلاب على حكم الرئيس محمد
مرسي انه تم العبث القضائي والعبث الاداري
باصدار قرارات قضائيه باعتبار جماعه
الاخوان جماعه ارهابيه يعني هذا لاحق
بالمز التي ات بحق جماعه الاخوان يعني اذا
طيب اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن غرفه رابعه
فالذي ينبغي ان يحاكم يعني ك غرفه رابعه
هي الغم التي ضمت عبد الفتاح السيسي وحزم
الببلاوي ومحمد ابراهيم وكل هذه القيادات
التي اتخذت قرار ارتكاب هذه المجزره هل من
دلالات اخرى استاذ اسعد هيكل هل من دلالات
اخرى لالغاء احكام الادام وتخفيف احكام
المؤبد وتبرئه 21 اخرين كما قلت يعني يا
استاذ عبد الصمد الظرف السياسي تغير من لم
يدرك ان الظرف السياسي تغير هو لا يقرا
المشهد جيدا يعني كانت هناك ظروف اخرى
سياسيه ضاغطه ادت الى وصول جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين بما يشير اليه الاستاذ وائل انهم
كان وزير الدفاع يعني يعطيهم التحيه وما
الى ذلك هذه الجماعه يعني في الحقيقه
انقلبت هي اول من انقلب على ثوره 25 يناير
وهي التي استاثرت بالحكم واقصد كل القوى
السياسيه القائمه كان هناك في هذا الوقت
تصريحا لها بمارسه نشاطها السياسي في شكل
حزب لكن استمرار هذه الجماعه بعد اعتصام
رابعه في نفس نهجها القديم وردتها في
الحقيقه الى اتخاذ العنف ووسائل مجابهه
الدوله المصريه بل ايضا مجابهه الثوره
المصريه والنشطاء لعلنا نذكر يعني
مواجهتهم للسوار في جمعه كشف الحساب وفي
جمعه رد الاعتبار في المقم وتسببهم في قتل
العديد من النشطاء السياسيين على راسهم
الحسين ابو ضيف مثلا كل هذه امور تغيرت
وبالتالي حينما قلت في البدايه ان القاضي
حينما يحكم هو القاضي بشر يتاثر بالظروف
السياسيه المحيطه وعلى ذكر القضات هنا
استاذ اسعد هيكل ذكر القضاه والسؤال لوائل
قنديل ه هذا اول حكم يصدر عن محكمه مصريه
بعد قانون السلطه القضائيه الجديده الذي
اثار اثار غضب القضاه في في مصر هل استاذ
وائل قنديل ترى لذلك اي علاقه باحكام
اليوم
المخففه لا ارى اي علاقه القضاء مازال
جزءا من منظومه الحكم الحاليه القضاء لم
يبدي اي ممانعه او ض اي
امتعاض لقرار عبد الفتاح السيسي او
القانون الذي اقر في برلمان عبد الفتاح
السيسي
بهيمنة سلطه عبد الفتاح السيسي اسعد هيكل
له تعليق اسعد هيكل يعني يعني احد اسباب
احد اسباب هو تحريل موقف الموقف بالنسبه
لقانون السلطه القضائيه وتدخل السلطه
التنفيذيه في اعمال القضاء هم جماعه
الاخوان احد الاسباب في الحقيقه في الموقف
السلب للقوى الوطنيه من هذه القوانين
بممارستهم التي لازالوا يتشدقون بها كما
تحدث الاستاذ وائل بما يسميه الرئيس
الانقلاب ومزج هذه في الحقيقه مصطلحات
عافى عليها الزمن وتجاوزنا ب مراحل خلينا
الان نبحث في امر سياسي جديد هو
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله ونترك مثل
هذه الترهات في الحقيقه التي اضاعت جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وقتا طويلا في استهلاكها
واضاعت على القوى الوطنيه فرص كثيره
لاصلاح الوضع السياسي القائم سواء فيما
يتعلق بقانون السلطه القضيه او غيره من
الامور السياسيه طيب استاذ سعد هيكل يعني
الحديث عن تخفيف الاحكام
السياسيه ربما قد يره البعض بانه مبالغ
فيه بحكم ان هذه احكام جاءت بينما صدرت
احكام اخرى من محكمه عسكريه في الاسكندريه
احكام بالمؤبد اين هو التخفيف اذا يعني
انت انت تشير الى احكام قديمه يعني انت
تشير والقضاء العسكري له طبيعه خاصه ولعلك
تذكر استاذ عبد الصمد اننا نهضنا احنا
كقوه مدنيه غير احنا نهضنا اولا مساله
محاكمه المدنين امام القضاء العسكري م ص
اليوم وليس قديمه استاذ الاحكام الاحكام
اليوم في
الاسكندريه انا اقول ان القضاء العسكري له
طبيعه خاصه ونحن نهضنا مساله وقاومنا
الاخوان المسلمين حينما وضع نصا في دستور
2012 يجيز محاكمه المدنين امام القضار
العسكري اما الاحكام التي صدرت المحكمه
المدنين انا استطيع اعزيها الا الى ان
القضاء المصري اليوم حكم بشكل قانوني مجرد
اذا كنت تشير الى وثيقه سياسيه صدرت من
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ابدوا فيها نوعا
من التنازل سموها الاصطفاف الوطني صدرت
عندا وطن وما الى ذلك انا اقول ان ان حده
المواجهه خففت او اصبحت في اريحيه بشكل ما
بين جماعه الاخوان والمسلمين والسلطه وان
القضاء في نهايه الامر هو قاضي هو مواطن
فقط فقط نعم اعيد التاكيد مره اخرى بان
الاحكام التي تحدثت عنها الاحكام الصادره
عن المحكمه العسكريه في اسكندريه هي صدرت
اليوم فقط من باب يعني تحيين المعلومات
السؤال الاخير وائل قنديل يعني كل
قيادات الاخوان اليوم يحاكمون في عشرات
القضايا في ص صراع ام يوصف بالسياسي هل
يمكن حسم هذا الصراع برايك نعم في ردهات
المحاكم وباح كام
قضائيه لا طبعا انا كما قلت لك يعني اذا
اردت ان ان تقتل قضيه عادله في مصر اذهب
بها الى القضاء يعني ولنا في طيران
وصنافير العبره يعني وبالتالي انا فقط
اريد ان اشير الى اني لا اتحدث باسم جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ثانيا
انه القول بان سلطه لابيه و يعني هناك
اشياء لا تسقط بالتقادم هناك جرائم يعني
الكيان الصهيوني سيظل اسمه الكيان
الصهيوني رغم ان الامر الواقع يقول ان
اسرائيل مسيطره قائد الانقلاب سيظل قائد
الانقلاب رغم انه يتمتع يعني بحمايه
اقليميه ودوليه بالضبط يعني واي يعني اذا
اذا كان هناك لص او [__] يعني اطلق لحيه
وامسك مسبحه و سيبقى لص او قوادا في نهايه
المطاف وبالتالي الكلام عن ان ان الاخوان
اص يعني انا مش فاهم انا برد على ايه
وثيقه ومره واصلحنا مش عارف عمل وقانون
السلطه القضائيه نحن الان بصدد واقعه
حقيقيه هذا القضاء مسيس يصدر احكاما
سياسيه في اللحظه اللي اللي بيصدر فيها
احكام بتخفيف عقوبات على ابرياء بالاساس
السلطه نفسها بتصفي وبتقتل ونريد تحقيقا
في عمليات القتل خارج القانون التي تمت
اليوم وعمليات القتل التي حدثت في ربعه
العدويه وفي كل ميادين مصر خارج القانون
وبالتالي انا اؤكد مره اخرى غرفه عمليات
رابعه هي غرفه عمليات ارتكاب مذبحه رابعه
العدويه هي التي يعني اذا كان هناك عداله
ناجزه حقيقه فينبغي ان تكون هذه هي موضوع
المحاكمه وليس الضحايا الذين قتلوا والذين
اصيبوا والذين شردوا في كل مكان شكرا لك
مع تحفظي
على ما قلت قبل قليل لصا او كذا شكرا لك
وائل قنديل الكاتب الصحفي انا بتكلم في
المطلق يعني بتكلم في العموم هناك جمهور
وهناك اسر تتابعنا و يسمح لنا بان نسمح
بمثل هذه التعبيرات ليسمعها الجمهور شكرا
لك وائل قنديل الكاتب الصحفي لندن كما
اشكر من القاهره عبر سكايب اسعد هيكل
المحامي والباحث
السياسي هواجس ايران الامنيه على حدودها
مع باكستان القت بثقلها على العلاقات بين
طهران واسلام بعدد الجمل تناقش تعقيدات
العلاقات بين البلدين الجارين في المحطه
الاخيره من حصاد اليوم